to visit one place in the world right
now bless you there is a like Thousand
Mile garage sale that happens in August
of every year like I've been dying to go
garage selling is like genuinely a hobby
of mine so I would go to like a small
town in Tennessee to their garage sale
wow
wow it really wasn't expected
that goes back to the way this all
started self-awareness yeah yeah I don't
get as much enjoyment at a three-star
Michelin in France even though that's
rad because I love food and wine I'm on
in Utah like what a place like you can
really rest the Jets game like one of my
favorite places to go Madison Square
Garden these are great Joys but there's
something super weird for me personally
about going to a garage sale that is
like so calming and fun and I love it